ich fahre zu diesem action der 20
kilometer von ihr ist geht da rein alle
ausverkauft dann dachte ich mir ja gut
festhalten doch zu dem nachbarn die
bären gewonnen haben ich war zudem nach
vorn herein alle ausverkauft noch ein
weiter hinter wurden alle ausverkauft
und da war ich so sauer dass diese
scheiße zeigen was das denn hier keine
lust aufzustehen haben was haye hätte
was vorher zu bekommen
zu allen neun muss man ja kann man ja
direkt am anfang sagen habt ihr schon am
kopf her gesehen habe schon am titel
gesehen und heute testen war eigentlich
wollte ich dich scheiße gar nicht dass
ich weiß warum ich bin dem sich vor 14
wochen morgens losgefahren wo die
rausgekommen sind oder wo er mich darauf
hingewiesen habe er hier bei action die
aber auch gerade erfolgs im angebot also
halt erfolgs und das ist irgendwie in
köln gaben kein action der nächste
action ist 20 kilometer von hier und in
bonn ganz auf welche ich fahre zu diesem
action der 20 kilometer von ihr ist geht
da rein alle ausverkauft dann dachte ich
mir ja gut fährt auch zu den nachbarn
die werden die wohl haben ich war zudem
noch von jeder rein alle ausverkauft war
ich noch ein weiter hat hintergrund alle
ausverkauft
und da war ich so sauer dass ich diese
scheiße zeichen nicht weg auf sich nimmt
was morgens um acht uhr ich war um 10
uhr da verstehe ich nicht so gut so ist
das anscheinend jetzt habe ich sie doch
bekommen
für zehn euro maria für die gekauft und
damit gemacht und da dachte ich mir wenn
du jetzt schon hier liegen kann man sich
ja auch mal testet das lustig ist wir
haben genau gerade die airports
drogentest alter es hört man echt mal
richtig leid jetzt ist ja so und
wahrscheinlich auch noch richtig
geklotzt
da wird mir jetzt ein bisschen
schwindelig schon bei und die war schon
krank
deswegen ist dieser unterschied
wahrscheinlich jetzt noch viel größer
als er sonst eh schon wäre aber gut ich
bin nicht voreingenommen und paktiert
sein muss jetzt ein bisschen brutal
[Musik]
übrigens ihr euch das mal aus gefunden
so für die verpackungen sind wir sollten
werden wegen diebstahl schützen
ich habe auch nicht ganz verstanden wie
genau ich hab mir da nämlich gedacht
kommt das ist einmal macht bewusst in
eine tasche und gehst raus hat geklappt
also gute wirklich einen diebstahl
helfen spaß
ich glaube ja nicht mal selber gekauft
[Applaus]
ja ich muss sagen sehen ein bisschen aus
wie 7 oder alter noch so ganz normales
kabel main wo ich beim letzten mal
ich habe das müsste man 325 sein und ja
mal die kopfhörer ein bisschen bisschen
eckig aus kummer so als hätten die so
einen buckel und hier das case das
klappt wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder so
alter meister noch weil wir uns immer
die von tedi so witzig gemacht haben
jetzt ist man es ja irgendwie gewohnt
muss hier so wein und dann so ganz
vorsichtig auf ok dann stecke ich das
ding mal hier rein
zack zack leuchten beide schon das heißt
strom fließt ich wollte mal ganz kurz
was holen und zwar gut ich muss sagen
ich habe hier auch noch kein gewinner
ermittelt weil ich dir eigentlich mal
bei ins tableau sei das mache ich
allerdings noch ich habe jetzt noch hier
stehen die haben wir auch gerade vor
zwei tagen getestet und diese hier vor
einer woche glaube ich dass hier sind
nicht die iso ts mini und ich wollte mal
kurz zu checken inwiefern die sich
ähneln
nur so ein bisschen schon eine
ähnlichkeit ist da und dann habe ich
hier noch nie länger von kaufland und da
ist mir aufgefallen
hier der deckel ist ähnlich obwohl
nehmen ist doch quatsch was erzähle ich
hatte ich irgendwie falsch weil ich habe
viele kommentare bekommen dass diese
dinger hier von action die i7 tv ist
sein sollen tbs steht übrigens für true
weil es ihr was beim letzten mal wusste
ich das nicht mal komme ich befasse mich
seit über einem monat aktiv mit airports
und lustiges tws bedeutet man wird
schlapp auf jeden fall hat das gerne
andere gemeint und eine gewisse
ähnlichkeit ist da ich muss hier
allerdings sagen dass ich schon besser
finde vom design her
sieht so ein bisschen hochwertiger aus
hochwertig und anfangs steht und die
minis hier glaube ich damals bei amazon
gekauft war noch komplett also braucht
kein mensch gut soviel dazu dann würde
ich sagen wir testen die soundcheck
mikrofon check distanz check jetzt kann
ich kurz teil enya drückt nein
scheiße was machen wir da jetzt so
verstehen wir kollekten war die masche
im handy ich hoffe das geht flüssig
drücke ich mal hier auf gut glück da
muss ich überschreibung beschließen und
funktioniert nein halt manchmal denken
können weil hier ist es so man tut die
wahrscheinlich ins ohr drückt dann hier
drauf und hier und da haben wir auch
schon hier schauen wir mit 8100 8108
1902 kein plan sieht das durchaus nicht
so ne immer noch einmal das original
vielleicht um das zu vergleichen
ja wir sind schon das sind schon wieder
so richtig nette dinge komme auch die
ohrmuschel dick und wiegt nicht mal die
hälfte wieder das heißt nichts gutes
naja wir kommen zum soundcheck verbunden
bin ich hatte mal kommen das ist auch so
ein mysterium jetzt ich bin einmal
verbunden mit den airports von jahr und
den ovationen das heißt ich bin mir zwei
verschiedenen connected wie ihr das denn
dann trenne ich mich mal hier kurz von
denen ja danke und jetzt machen wir den
soundcheck 3 2 1
gruppe g
[Musik]
das sind mit abstand die schlechtesten
die wir getestet haben
ich habe noch nie so etwas grausames
gehört hört ihr das woanders ist dass
ihre martini geben hier spricht dass
wegen körperverletzung das ganz kurz
notieren also dass das und zehn euro das
ist mir dafür gegeben dass ihr ins ohr
stecke das kind ja so also ich hab ich
habe schon viele nachrichten bekommen
von leuten die meinen ich hab die
kompletter müll aber auch leute die
geschrieben haben sind eigentlich in
ordnung
nein nein das hat mir schon schlechteren
eine das also ich weiß nicht was ich
sagen soll ich mal ganz kurz noch
distanz check wobei ich glaube in diesem
ganzen kram es ist das gleiche bluetooth
teil verbunden das heißt die distanz ist
aber in ordnung oder kann es sein
vor unserem versteht ihr dann wichtige
fakten die eine gruppe zu und vielleicht
ist ja auch noch mal das macht man ja
aber was ist das irgendwie nicht noch
mal halt manchmal im sommer spielen da
raus obwohl das sagt noch nichts sonst
werden die play offs angelockt ich habe
da nichts tut aber ich weiß nicht ob es
normal ist also ich habe es früher nicht
gemacht ich war so und das verrückte
hier ist auch die haben gar kein sender
dafür ob ihr es im ort oder nicht die
musik läuft durch wird das war auch bei
anderen zone main ich naja also absolut
hammel mikrofone jack warner und dann
spreche ich die gegen die wand verlost
die dort will sie nicht vernünftig diese
euch verlosen ich will kein wunder
zuschauer so etwas antun sollen also
leute zu boden gefallen und holt euch
diese teile auf gar keinen fall folgt
meinem rad wohl durch die 1000 m s
solide 30 euro ist in ordnung aber so
was hier für 10 euro da könnt ihr die 10
euro auch gleich mehr geben oder davor
in die mülltonne stecken ich rufe die
mal kurz an
okay die qualität ist richtig es richtig
ktf gezählt doch mal ein bisschen es war
ja also man versteht schon damals ist
echt scheiße drei von uns erwartet haben
wir das auch okay leute wir sind wieder
am ende ein nächster airport fekter ist
wirklich super gern mein video endlich
dass die airports pro ich bin am
überlegen ob ich diese serie noch
weiterführen soll es gibt noch viele
modelle auf dem markt die ich bestellen
könnte zum einen sind auch noch die von
lidl auf meiner liste für die ich mich
sehr interessieren
ich sehe allerdings bis heute nicht
bekommen habe aber ich habe gehört die
sind bald wohl wieder erhältlich sondern
werden natürlich auch von mir getestet
ich hoffe ihr habt da weiterhin bock
drauf weil ich habe und am letzten doch
das ein oder andere mal gelesen so
langsam reicht's mit den erp- und videos
aber es macht mir spaß und irgendwie bin
ich gerade auch so richtig da drin in
diesem thema deswegen ich hoffe es gibt
immer noch genug leute die sich dafür
interessieren
falls sie eine
heute zeigt kommen da sehr gerne nach
oben da lassen oder das sind die
kommentare schreiben
aber wir den kanal aktiviert die glocke
und wir sehen uns dann zum beinahe von
instagram account alex wie soll ich hier
so verlosen ich wahllos dieser story
obwohl mir dass ich auf jeden fall
werden auch meinem account öfter mal
sachen verlost sich in meinen videos
vorstellen wir haben demnächst auch
wieder ein paar coole sachen dran willst
und so weiter es wird lustig zu folgen
wir sehen uns dort rein
[Musik]